I thought that all it took was me to  know I was gay and then I'd be gay but  it are you gay yeah yeah  okay let's pause for a second I'm not  [Music]  you know this kind of couples that they  spend like ten years together  and they get married they divorce in one  year just go and have fun with the  things you have right there yeah like  this this whole night we should do this  for like 24 hours straight it's like  dating too I guess  yeah I want to see you getting angry  you're so beautiful  so did I haven't said yes to anything in  so long it's like she lives in a way  that she doesn't question anything about  herself  [Music]  lutely yeah I've never actually gotten  close enough to somebody to love them  you know you should try not to go for  the easy thing  you can play it safe in love you have to  just go anytime  [Music]  you